get this guy over there it's pitch black
we've got our anchor line out and so do
a bunch of other boats around them we've
got to make sure that our fish doesn't
come in contact with any of the other
anchor lines in the water or we'll be
out a huge paycheck this is going crazy
right now we've got the anchor line
right here we're trying to back away
from the anchor we get away from the
anchor we should be in good position
definitely a big pointy icon size right
line straight ahead
let's get out of here move around
on the guifang of all over here we can
we do sighs dangerous so now the other
guy right here strikes out Jen get an
anchor back to drag off inside the
getting wrapped in grow back that
dragged on back that's right off
other background resizing of all
mistakes look I was tying up to get off
the stand applause thank you Thanks
right now our fish is wrapped around
another guy's anchor ball and our goal
is to gas the anchor ball and untangle
it without losing our fish don't put any
pressure on cap something dangling
fangled hurry up
did you still on hold
lost of
grow long
it's so much fun I don't want to cut the
guys name for fear soon as much it sucks
I'd rather lose a fish and do something
crappy to another fisherman I just don't
need the bad karma on my boat all you
can do is go back up line again get
lightly I think to drop out to anchor
appreciate it full boat no problem sorry
you lost it just Tyler lost the fish
awesome good go in there man you made
your right call and all my years of
fishing you know I've learned one thing
you got to try and put out good karma
and usually good karma results a good
fishing in return
[Music]
you
[Music]